hi i'm beryl and today i am a guest on
buzzfeed's channel
hello normally i make videos over on my
own channel
okay now hold on very interesting
and there i take one theme and i tend to
cook different iterations of it around
the world with the help of my
subscribers
so things like comfort food or sick
foods or
things as basic as instant noodles it is
one of my favorite things to do
i think that instant noodles are so
approachable and everybody has access to
them
everywhere in the world so i went to
buzzfeed's community page and i asked
you all
how you personally make instant noodles
what your favorite recipe
is and today i'm gonna be cooking two of
them
we have a dish from new zealand and a
dish from
south korea you know just before we go
ahead i'm gonna say this again these are
personal recipes
these aren't like a nationally known
dish necessarily so
if you haven't heard from them maybe you
can give them a try
okay with that let's start
so we're starting with ramen grilled
cheese that was submitted by somebody in
new zealand
actually i'm gonna use maggie instant
noodles this is one of my favorite
brands i always have it in the house
bringing out my portable stove and
if you don't pour out the little extra
bits in the bottom of the ramen bag
you're a monster okay i'm adding the
spices and i did mess up here
for anyone who's gonna copy this you
don't wanna add the spices
because you're gonna drain it see so i'm
breaking an egg
whisking it up and i'm gonna add this
vegan chickenless seasoning
it's pretty much the same as a spice
packet this is gonna help give the
noodles
flavor i'm mixing the egg yolk into the
noodles
and cutting up some green onion which
i'm gonna put into this noodle mixture
and i'm gonna bring all of this and put
it on top of a hot
flat pan in essence i'm making the bread
so like little
noodle pancakes and the egg is gonna
cook them
all together kind of like like a latke
okay i've picked my two favorites and
i'm now going to add
mozzarella cheese in the middle and make
the sandwich
which i'm going to cover you know that
residual heat will hopefully make it
melt better
the final product looks good cutting
into it cheese pull
that's pretty impressive it looks really
good
[Music]
okay a um grilled cheese ramen sandwich
the ingenuity of you all just never
ceases
to amaze me
um yes this is
this is very delicious
a little messy maggie hot and sweet
literally my favorite condiment i talk
about it constantly
i feel like it just needs like a little
something
oh 80 to 100 just like that
second side this also really reminds me
of this instant noodle pancake that i
made from malaysia in one of my other
episodes
oh yeah yeah oh my god
that one had like meat in it and a lot
of vegetables and the whole thing was
cooked together
last bite definitely
um messy but
[Music]
i like it's messy and then i touch my
hair delicious
now we're gonna try the other one okay
my second noodle i'm calling the spicy
cheesy ramen it was submitted
from south korea the recipe says to use
shin
ramyun and i use the spicy kind
so i'm gonna be boiling my water and
typical i have run out of gas these
things
are the worst okay water is boiling
we're back in the game putting all of my
spices in and now i'm adding gochujang
if you've never had that this is a red
pepper paste it's spicy it's got a
little bit of sweetness and this
beautiful beautiful red color once my
noodles are done
i am going to fry up an egg and why does
the egg
always slide into the corner of the pan
why
my counter is flat okay plating it up
i'm kind of doing a bit of a terrible
job adding the mozzarella cheese now
when it's still hot so that it will melt
in there
topping it with my fried egg and for me
i always need to
add a pop of color just makes it look
nicer and that
looks amazing boom i have dubbed this
one the
spicy cheesy ramen and it smells
so good gochujang is just
it's beautiful it is the perfect type of
spice flavor i think
i mean let's see how i do with this i'm
not a wimp
but i've had my moments
i just need i just need a quick drink
just just one second
oh my god
no okay this is it's got spice but it's
good we're okay
it's creamy and spicy and the noodles
are cooked
very well the egg yolk is a very nice
combination i mean
anytime you put a fried egg on anything
i believe that it upsets value
that's a personal statement
[Music]
i feel like really what this is about is
that instant noodles might be pretty
basic but
the ability to dress them up is endless
there are so many possibilities and you
can make it
so much more than just a plain pack of
noodles
that's kind of everything um i'm gonna
sit here and finish my noodles and if
you guys want to see more videos like
this or
other foods because i cook a lot over on
my channel
i'm going to leave a link below um and
otherwise
i will see you all later
you